so remember when like Russia was
meddling in the American election and
everyone was really afraid and it was
this terrible thing it turns out that um
this is something that the U.S has done
forever like one of the things that the
U.S has done a ton over the course of
its history is throw out leaders in
other countries that it doesn't like or
meddle in their elections or in their
politics that's what a coup is and the
U.S got really into this especially
during the Cold War they would send the
CIA in to like go foment protests and
stuff and eventually oust the leader
sometimes they would like actually just
like full-on like assassinate the leader
have been all over the world in fact
I've been like deep in this trying to
map all of the different coups way too
many for me to cover so I just settled
on like 17 of them that were
particularly fascinating and terrific
and I think after spending a lot of time
thinking about Coos it was just a
reminder for me that we think we live in
this world of like order and like
there's rules and treaties and all this
stuff but at the end of the day
countries with the most power they're
gonna get their way no matter what